le président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
premier ministre je souhaite vous
interroger à partir de mon expérience
celle d'une élue qui a vu progresser
dans nos quartiers
le communautarisme qui a vu les jeunes
femmes se mettre le voile porté le voile
sous la pression alors que leur mère
sans été libérés le voile en 2019 n'est
pas anodin et nous aurions tort de le
considérer comme une expression d'une
pratique religieuse d'ailleurs beaucoup
de femmes musulmanes dans notre pays ne
le porte pas le voile est trop souvent
le symbole d'un islam politique qui
considèrent plus la femme comme un objet
soumis que comme un individu un individu
émancipé pour reprendre un qualificatif
cher au président de la république nous
aurions tort de baisser les yeux et ne
pas voir que le port de signes religieux
ostentatoires dans le cadre des sorties
scolaires est un instrument de
prosélytisme et parfois même de
provocation l'école de la république
doit montrer aux petites filles qu'elles
ne transige pas avec les principes de
laïcité et d'égalité
or sur cette question centrale du
respect de la laïcité et de la
neutralité régit le religieuse et
adultes intervenant dans le cas de
l'école hors les murs la majorité et le
gouvernement se divise vous avez tenté
monsieur premier mise de désamorcer les
querelles au sein de votre majorité mais
une fois de plus vous avez en définitive
baisser les bras vous ne cessez de dire
qu'il faut lutter contre le
communautarisme et en même temps vous ne
cessez de renoncer à agir
ce n'est pas l'ambiguïté qui contribuera
au réarmement moral de notre pays et au
respect des principes qui font la france
et qui unissent les français
monsieur le premier ministre pouvait me
dire exactement ce que le gouvernement
compte faire vraiment pour lutter contre
la communautarisation de notre société
et faire respecter les principes de
notre république laïque et indivisible